just to take one example now we have
this chat GPT and already students are
using it to write their papers and
professors are using it to write their
lectures right so it's like two machines
talking to each other you know or for
example you know there are these
programs you can speak into it and then
it'll translate it into Spanish or
something like this so but every step
that we take in that direction our human
capacities like Reading Writing and so
forth begin to sort of rust and disuse
yeah not only do they rough and disuse
but at some point there'll be a kind of
cannibal element once they reode to open
chat GPT and it starts to now continue
to analyze what's coming in terms of
writing and in terms of it'll start to
eat its own children yeah and it'll
create a cannibalistic monster that will
start to devolve because it's going to
be it's basically cycling back its own
its own output
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so hello everyone I am very excited to
be back with Jacob Holland he has been
on the podcast before he is the Provost
of the University of Austin and he is an
expert both on Ancient thinking in terms
of uh the ancient Greeks and but also uh
biblical thinking as well and rabbinical
thinking so this is going to be a great
conversation we want to talk about the
question of technology and all the way
leading up to the the issues of AI and
all that so Jacob this is you're the
you're exactly the person I want to have
this conversation with well thanks I
feel the same way so my big question my
first question for you is have you
thought a bit about the different
narratives about technology that we find
both in ancient thinking whether
mythological or philosophical and the
the way that the Bible portrays the the
the question of Technology let's say
yeah I mean you know I think that a lot
of the issues that we're confronting
today were already
identified
um by both of those traditions
um and maybe one way to put it is uh if
we go back to the platonic text Plato
makes a distinction between
um acquisition and production as sort of
kinds of Sciences or Arts
um
and philosophy is categorized under
acquisition what does that mean the
acquisition
of knowledge which is a kind of openness
or receptivity to the world right so
there's a kind of anthropology behind
this human beings are these Souls that
relate fundamentally to reality
um and our job if you will is to
register those realities and to take
them in now production is I mean the
Greek word is poiasis which is could
also be translated poetry but it just
means production making
um
and the thing is that
there's no
pure receptivity I guess I would say if
if you're doing Philosophy for example
you and this is really the ancient
Circle epistemology you register right
what is there and then you articulate it
there's no philosophy without
articulation
um but that's that always has a
productive Dimension you're using the
tools that you have generated for
example language you're selecting which
of those tools
um you're going to employ I mean you
could you could represent reality
mathematically or poetically or whatever
um and so there's always this kind of
productive element you're adding to
um to what it is that you've taken in
technology from the Greek perspective
and I think this applies to the Bible as
well
is a kind that is obviously productive
because we're making stuff we're
transforming nature we're building
um
and the danger there is that it can
interpose itself
um between us and reality and that
ultimately if we sort of follow the line
of technological development far enough
and here I would sort of flag AI
we might create a kind of virtual
reality that is to say a humanly
produced reality that substitutes for
the world uh to which this philosophical
and I would say biblical anthropology
suggests that we are fundamentally meant
to be open and to order ourselves mind
yeah I think that that so I you know one
of the the things that I read even in
college also because of postmodernists
really is the Plato's feedra where
Socrates talks about writing itself as
having that problem which is something
that a lot of modern people would be
surprised because we we we're actually
like Beyond writing it's like whatever
effects writing had on the civilization
we're Way Beyond it but in some ways it
was exactly that problem which is that
we as humans are living Spirits right we
we are breathing living spirits that
that that manifest meaning that take in
meaning and but there's a kind of
organic dance to that right uh whereas
as soon as you fix something
then it on the one hand it makes it more
powerful because right you can send your
texts out you can send emails out but on
the other hand it does in fact it can in
fact interpose itself the way you said
it's a supplement it's an it's an adding
to language and then it can become a
kind of opacity to what it is that
you're that you're saying you know if
we're talking you know you and I face to
face
and you don't understand what I'm saying
you know you can ask me and I can answer
and then we can have this kind of back
and forth where we're tuning in and
we're tuning closer to what we want but
if you read a text that's what it is
that's it like that's what you have
and so you it'd be it can so on the one
hand it makes it possible for me to
access the thoughts of people that I
that I can't meet but it also at the
same time creates that difficulty which
is that
you know it's like this these fixed
words are my vision of what what what it
is that's coming down to me you know
it's a means let's say uh but it can it
can become something of an idol like
because
if we lose its connection to what it
originally is then it then it somehow
has a life of its own you could say and
it's interesting because a lot of the
postmoderns that's actually what they
want to do they want to like Liberate
the text from the author in some weird
way like make it have a kind of Life of
its own uh where there is no there's no
there's no like thread that goes back to
the to the person but rather it becomes
almost something that you play with you
know just that on it's at its own level
yeah I think that's right you know
the features is really interesting
because I mean there are these
interesting kind of contradictions so
this is a written platonic dialogue yeah
thank goodness it's written because we
have access to the thinking of Plato but
um the little story there is
um two Egyptians one is the Pharaoh and
one's a god writer talking
um and uh
uh one of them is displaying the Arts
that he's produced and finally gets to
writing uh and the objection that the
other registers is that um uh this will
not be a tool of memory that is to say
when writing is introduced the idea is
we're not going to forget stuff because
we've written it down increase memory
is the is the argument of the of the God
and the God is like uh he's almost like
a Hephaestus figure he's like a kind of
dark God of Technology yes right right
conversion yeah exactly yeah oh and and
I mean as a side note it's interesting
that this takes place in Egypt because I
would suggest that Egypt with its man
God it's Pharaoh
um it's magicians who exercise some kind
of Techni right and causing little
miracle little you know
strange like unnatural events to occur
and so forth
um it's
enormously impressive technological
achievements by which I mean for example
uh the pyramids or
um I mean I was in Egypt a number of
years ago and I have to say I've never
seen more exquisite jewelry I mean just
the you know when you take sort of the
sarcophagi and all these things but
what's interesting is so Egypt devoted
um tremendous social resources to the
production of these kinds of items and
obelisks and huge things like this
what were they for primarily they were
to honor uh and be stuffed in the tombs
of dead man Gods okay I should say
incidentally that
um Egypt was also a kind of symbol in
the ancient world I mean Plato
Associates that it with um with death
with a kind of um desiccation a lack of
life okay and I would want to connect
that as a long discourse perhaps but
with technology as a kind of substitute
okay so anyway
um the god points out
uh this will actually be a tool of
forgetfulness and the suggestion is um
and what he means by there is is or let
me put another way
um it will be it will suppress
recollection in a philosophical sense
which I would take to mean something
like a living openness to the
fundamental things that need
metaphysically
religiously and so forth to be
remembered by us to be taken into our
souls so you're absolutely right writing
that search is a kind of mediation right
and obviously today
um
um where young people and maybe not even
that young people
um have have sort of learned to not to
answer the phone but to use text and so
forth
um there are all kinds of further layers
of mediation between human beings so
Socrates favored this face-to-face
discussion like we're having now and I
do think that um you know if we look at
again artificial intelligence just just
consider the levels of mediation that
are involved in when I sort of look at
my smartphone or something like that or
when I'm relating to you know a glowing
electronic screen
um
uh what's happening there human beings
are observing the world they are
representing it in language or
mathematics or something they're then
encoding it into Data zeros and ones and
then that is being presented to us right
so there's a kind of I mean we've taken
writing and kind of amplify put it on
steroids if you will so I think this is
a really important issue definitely and
the all the the imagery that happens in
fedris is related to this and it's
actually very similar to the one that
you find in the Bible that the way that
Egypt is represented also in in this
text with all of the other symbolisms
that BR that are brought about in fidris
it's similar to the way Egypt is
represented in scripture because fidros
and Socrates leave the city they cross
they leave their city and they cross a
river you know it's like when you cross
a river you know what that means like
you're either going out into the
Wilderness or you're coming into the
into into your home you could say so
they cross a river and then there are
all these weird things that Socrates
does I was like sometimes he talks he
covers his face and talks through a veil
and there's all these these kind of
weird symbolic things that Socrates is
doing and it seems to manifest what what
I've talked about quite a bit in
scripture which is the garments of skin
uh I think that the imagery of the
garments of skin in scripture is very
much akin to what is happening in this
idea of the supplement that Plato is
trying to to help us see which is the
garments of skin on the one hand what
they do is that they increase your
capacity to live in a world that's
hostile to you right but that's what
they do but at the same time they are
made out of death first of all and they
are also a weakening of you at the same
time because you're always putting
yourself in more danger as you're moving
out so that's what and that seems to be
what technology does in general and has
to do with recollection as well so think
about
think about the example I love to use
all the time is is fire making so my
ancestors could spend a lot of energy
they knew how to make fire but it would
take forever and they would use a string
and a bow or whatever they would use and
they could just kind of and even that
they needed the string in the bow but
they could they could make fire it's
like I don't have to think about that I
just have to flick a lighter
and I have fire so I'm I'm a million
times more powerful than my ancestors
but if I don't have that lighter I'm
going to die of cold in the forest
pretty much and so it's like think of
Technology if you think of technology
that way which is that even we've
increased our power to the extent that
we can move out and go into space and
you know I can live here in Quebec where
there's like eight months of winter but
it so it makes me more powerful but it
also makes me closer it brings me closer
to death and makes me more fragile at
the same time and that seems to be what
technology itself does especially
writing and especially what we could
call now information technology
which is that I know I have access to
more information that all my ancestors
together
but I don't have to hold it inside me in
any way
so I can pretend to be smart and be a
complete idiot or not a total idiot but
I'm I'm far less integrated than you
know the Ancients would have been but I
also have all this access so I can it
can it's like it's that duality of of uh
of power and weakness or or like using
death against death maybe it's the best
way to describe it
yeah uh
it strikes me that there there's some
sort of optimal relationship between man
nature and Technology I mean you know
you're absolutely right so Adam and Eve
sin God prepares them clothes out of
animal skins obviously this then is a
fundamental divorce between human beings
and these animals with whom they
communed
in the garden
um yeah and also from God because they
use it it it when they first put on
coverings it's to hide themselves from
God right so they hide themselves from
God and then they buffer themselves from
the animal and they create this like
buffer between them and between God and
the animal they're like isolated in the
world or alienated is the best way to
word to use maybe so one of the things I
that flashed into my mind when you were
speaking was um Yuval harari's book um
sapiens in the beginning of that book he
makes a rather strong case I think uh
that the hunter-gathering age of our
existence was in some ways um
maybe the most intellectually
stimulating and kind of um Rich compared
to for example you know I'm an
accountant and I'm looking at a computer
screen all day why is that because
uh
individuals had to possess a range of
technical skills right you've got to be
able to kill animals you got to be able
to skin them you have to be able to sew
these garments you have to be able to
make fire you've got you know you have
to be able to identify plants to figure
to pick things and just sort of
respond to the occlusive nature now they
obviously live much closer to Nature the
thing about nature is that it's hostile
I mean we know this from the Bible we
know this from the Greeks
um it's not simply hostile right it's
also beautiful and Splendid and
nurturing and so forth but we have to
deal with the hostility element
um in fact I would I would actually if
you sort of ask me like what's work I
would categorize work as sorting chaos
right just kind of getting sort of
figuring things out so you can so you
can survive
um yeah work is a good though in
scripture too it's weird because it's
like it's a consequence of the fall but
it ends up being a way to be safe from
the fall both personally in terms of
your own soul but then also just because
now you do have to work the Earth to
make things grow but right that's that's
also how you survive yeah so so
obviously we're not hunter-gatherers
we've we've Advanced it you know it's
interesting because people still talk
about progress yeah and so what is
progress well progress is also a regress
right yeah
um and um and now we rely on all sorts
of things that we have no idea how they
work I mean this is something Ortega
said writes about in uh the Revolt of
the masses it's something Freud writes
about in Civilization and it's
discontents as well he speaks about
um a technological man as a kind of
prosthetic God
we put out all our stuff and we're you
might think of like a you know
in the anime like more enhanced with
exoskeletons exactly by it and stuff
like this um
and Technology obviously you know brings
discontents but
um what's interesting then is that uh we
are unable to reproduce the conditions
of our own existence in other words no
single person can do that
um uh thinker named rosenstakusi once
said that a citizen is a person who if
need be can refound civilization
in the modern world
there aren't any citizens by that
definition if you see what you mean I
mean well there might be citizens in the
sense that there could be people with
enough practical wisdom and so forth to
sort of refund political life but if
we're talking about civilization as we
now depend on it and we're utterly
dependent you're right
um that that becomes very difficult one
last thing I would say here is that
every technological advance
subtracts and this is obviously implicit
in what you were saying from our own
capabilities uh I'm gonna wave at
artificial intelligence again because
just to take one example okay now we
have this chat GPT
and already students are using it to
write their papers and professors are
using it to write their lectures right
so it's like two machines talking to
each other you know
um okay so why do I need or or for
example you know there are these
programs you can speak into it and then
it'll translate it into Spanish or
something like this so but every step
that we take in that direction our human
capacities like Reading Writing and so
forth begin to sort of rust and disuse
yeah not only do they rust and disuse
but at some point there'll be a kind of
cannibal element to the technology
because you know Chad GPT once once they
reode to open chat GPT and it starts to
now uh continue to analyze what's coming
in terms of writing and in terms of
they'll it'll start to eat its own
children yeah and it'll create a
cannibalistic uh cannibalistic monster
that will start to devolve because it's
going to be it's basically cycling back
its own its own output and so it's like
I don't see how they're going to solve
that problem in the in the long term
because right and but even the fact that
we know that it'll do that
is an image of what it's also doing to
us which is ultimately a kind of
diminishing of the human Spirit uh as it
is as it increases in power
yes look this is this is already
happening I mean weirdly Jonathan I took
some Solace from the fact that chat GPT
is cannibalizing itself in a way
um so just to be clear right uh
what does chatgpt do well it goes out
there in it and it kind of looks at all
this data right goes to the internet
right
um and uh which is not a particularly
intelligent pool on the average I mean
you just you know which is incidentally
why chat gbt makes stuff up that because
it obviously it sort of can't sort out
what's true or what's false
um and so it kind of looks at things and
makes these what it thinks are logical
connections but so that if you can just
calculate semantic distance right I mean
there was there was a uh a professor
told me about a paper he'd gotten on
Romeo and Juliet you know and it was
like Romeo you know the calculates and
the montages are worth and then Julia
catches a cab and she goes you know and
so I mean because this is right so
um so you kind of take this low pool and
you scoop it all up and you connect
these things and you spit something out
and then that becomes part of the larger
pool which the next chapter
you know looks at and and so so it's
sort of like consuming your own waste
now actually they cut they cut jtpd off
from they stopped training it a few
years ago oh they've actually cut it
it's only within itself but they can't
do that forever like I know they
probably did it because they know the
problem that they're setting up in the
world but at some point they're gonna
have to reopen it because they can't if
they want Chad gbt to keep up with
what's happening they'll have to reopen
it so that it goes back and starts to to
recount to re calculate so so I think
they're maybe they're looking for a
solution for it but they'd have at least
for now they have cut it off which is
which is something being hadn't done for
a while and that's why being was like a
psycho like Bing would would just go
into cycle mode and just become like
you're you're like you're you're you're
stalking ex-girlfriend or you know
turned into you know like the the like
passive aggressive or whatever like they
were all it had all these personality
defaults because it was literally
training on the internet so that's
that's really interesting um
but let's go back to your
cannibalization thing uh it it certainly
reminds me of you know a pagan God I
mean I think maybe in an earlier
discussion we we I observed that
um the biblical God feeds us right man
in the wilderness or Christ you know the
communion and so forth
um but the pagan gods really uh one
could argue and I won't do it right now
they they sort of dined on human beings
I mean you know think of like the the
um Athena and these various Gods you
know at Troy sort of sitting like
vultures they're compared to vultures
and they're just so hungry to consume
the bad the blood and so forth
um now what that means is that
again uh
human beings are relating only to
themselves but now through the mediation
of this artificial intelligence which is
why incidentally uh I I read somewhere
that like thousands of writers were
suing openai because
um it was training its language on
proprietarial works by these authors
which you've got to do because
the movement like if you just keep
training on
you know the internet you're going to
get you start at a low point and and
you're just kind of going to decline
it's going to be sort of mediocrity but
what that means is it needs to
cannibalize sort of living thinking
right it needs to like it needs these
human beings generating new stuff and
this is the large problem with our
society I mean even before these these
kinds of artificial intelligence
advances
Hollywood was cannibalizing itself right
you know I don't know such and such of
iteration seven right you know exactly
just Rambo 19 or something but think
here think let me throw something out
for you and see what you think about
this so one of the so if you look at the
Matrix movie so you have a situation
where the Matrix is this artificial
intelligence and it's feeding off of our
energy right so basically we're
batteries but what they mean by
batteries is something like the
electricity we produce there's something
a little naive about that the the way
that the AI actually works now is it's
it's actually farming intelligent from
humans so AI isn't intelligent but what
it does is that we provide
qualia we provide quality we provide
judgment to the AI so the way they
actually train the AI right is that the
eye generates a bunch of junk
and then there are people actual people
who have to look at that junk and say
yes no yes no good bad good bad they'll
use like the captions for example you
know like when you're when you're
answering a caption you're you're you're
like telling it where the the lights are
you're lit you're training AI when
you're doing that because AI doesn't
know the difference between uh a traffic
light and something else but if you've
got a million people telling telling the
AI oh that's a traffic light that's a
traffic light that's a traffic light
then you're then the humans you're
literally farming intelligence from
humans and so this weird thing where in
humans become like so now you have these
low paid you know uh Farms of people
that are like living in horrible like
offices and all they do all day is tell
the AI like what's even in terms of
social media and stuff like what's good
what's bad so you know that's all you do
even for like the social media companies
too like you have people all day all
they do is watch horrible content you
know like and then all they do is is
rated and say this is bad this is bad
this is bad so that Facebook can now
catch it automatically right so you
actually have the idea of this like
monster right this like this monster
that is eating our Attention our
intelligence and like subjugating us to
it but really like how can I say this
swallowing our soul like actually
swallowing our soul and it's like it's
happening in front of us that's that's
quite amazing
um and this brings up another thing
which is uh how does a child learn what
a cat is okay
um it encounters a cat and then someone
says that's a cat and it takes a couple
of iterations of this all right why
can't AI do it because human beings have
what the Ancients call intuition what's
intuition intuition is direct unmediated
access to reality now let me stop I can
imagine the skeptic listening and saying
oh wait a second of course it's mediated
right your brain Optical nerves this
whole thing is extremely complicated we
can start but let us say okay fine it's
all relative on the scale of Relativity
this is the most direct unmediated thing
um which is why frankly the we have a
critique of writing in Plato's fedris uh
because again writing is this mediation
and what needs to be preserved is this
capability of immediate intuition
Aristotle develops this and talks about
noises which is an intellectual
intuition right yeah we in the Orthodox
tradition the news and the idea of
noetic uh capacity is is the highest
form of of of knowledge right it's more
than knowledge in the sense of the way
that we think of thinking or whatever it
is is direct grasping and in in the
Orthodox kind of mystical theology The
Noose is the capacity we have to also be
United with God because it's the
capacity we have to have first of all
direct grasping of the things around us
but then ultimately it's that which also
makes us possible to like you know enter
into the Embrace of God because it's a
it's a type of knowledge that isn't just
intellectual it's it really is like the
fullness of your being you know uh
joining with something yes and look it's
um not simply knowledge of God but
knowledge of human beings I mean we
don't do this in English but you know
we've got um say in German someone might
say uh Kennedy Jonathan which means are
you familiar with Jonathan no one would
say visenzi Jonathan which means do I
have epistemic knowledge do I have a
scientific comprehension of Jonathan
um now I would argue that uh uh anything
that poses as a scientific comprehension
of Jonathan is not the best kind of
knowledge of Jonathan yeah um so if I
say oh he's a good guy or he's smart or
something like this this is a response
that is that that I have um that has
been elicited from me by my immediate
face-to-face presence with you and human
beings have a kind of inner Infinity
like God and that's something that we
cognized sort of directly
so but uh going back to
Ai and this cannibalistic stuff one
needs to raise the question of what do
we mean by intelligence
AI has Intelligence in a very specific
sense it's a kind of discursive
intelligence it goes across data and it
arranges it and moves it around it lacks
this intuition
so when we relate to AI generated
products we are relating to something
that has lost its Connection in some
basic or never had a connection never
had a derivative it's derivative
information necessary which is why you
know there's a kind of fundamental
stupidity
um you're you're a rather harrowing
picture of people sitting in a I imagine
a kind of you know windowless room
typing in like cat cat cat or whatever
uh suggests that you know like this this
it's like what does it mean that that is
the foundation of artificial
intelligence
um I had a professor who um very
cleverly said I I don't know why
everyone's interested in artificial
intelligence I'm looking for the real
thing right that's right real
intelligence that's hard enough to find
in the world already yeah exactly so
there's a kind of unmooring yeah um and
again if we go back to what I said at
the beginning of our discussion that
this kind of um biblical and Greek
anthropology is the soul is open to
reality both both the chaos of reality
and the and the kind of moral and
intellectual measures the you know
Transcendent Eternal things
um if that's the case then relating to
AI is is kind of shutting down of that
because we don't even have like AI
simply lacks any fundamental connection
or a direct connection with reality yeah
and I think that this is this is a good
place to to talk about how there's a
really a good a good way to understand
AI today is to understand the manner in
which idolatry was kind of understood
also in in scripture for example
um so if you want to take the idea of
technification because you talk about
like what's the right balance of
Technology like how can technology serve
as proper purpose so you have two images
in the Bible they're close to each other
because you know they're in the same
story which is on the one hand you have
the golden calf which Aaron builds
instead of the Revelation uh and people
end up worshiping the the calf itself uh
you know it's in worshiping the work of
their hands you could say and then the
other one is the revelation of the
Tabernacle which is a technical thing
like the the Tabernacle is like a little
city it is civilization it is like a
microcosm of civilization it's a
microcosm of of technicality there are
the use of metals of gold or silver and
a bronze you know in a in a in a in a
hierarchy there's this there's a whole
Cosmic image in the the Tabernacle later
in the temple
and that that seems to be the highest
image of what technology can be is an
ordered uh ordered supplementarity but
directed towards the Transcendence
directed toward the Transcendent and not
captured within its the fascination with
itself uh you know and a kind of
cannibalistic move where you the the
fascination of the technical itself
becomes the the or the capacity for
power itself becomes the the the the
motor which makes us engage with it yeah
this is so a bunch of ideas
um popped into my head as as you were
just speaking so the gold
um that made the golden calf as you know
was was Jewelry earrings and things like
this taken from Egypt
um now it was intended
for the adornment of the Tabernacle
what's really interesting there and this
just occurred to me is that that story
could be interpreted as an answer to the
question how do we
reorient technology how do we take it in
its really monstrous kind of
exemplification in Egypt and reorient it
toward I mean this is obviously
something that probably has occurred to
you but
um so let's talk about the golden calf
for a minute
so Moses is up there on the mountain
communing with God he doesn't come back
the Israelites say to Aaron you know the
guy's not coming back uh make us this
God
and there's this weird ventriloquism
that goes on because once Aaron makes
the calf which is definitely a technical
thing right he has to shape it and all
this kind of stuff
the Israelites say this is the Lord your
God who took you out of the land of
Egypt so they plagiarized God there's
there's another Act of cannibalism by
the way like in some sense or I don't
know if that's exactly right but
um and what is the what is the calf well
there's a weird connection between the
calf and what's going on today all right
um what uh are like what why do say
Americans love you know digital stuff
right well I mean if you ask anybody you
know what's the highest traffic on the
internet porn right
um technology by the way will generate
uh better and better sex robots and
things like this
um uh the golden calf
was I mean after they made the calf this
kind of uh
well somehow it stimulated this
bacchanalian celebration the next day so
like the cap is connected with the
unleashing of these desires which no
doubt were suppressed and Egypt these
people were slaves but here they are in
the desert and they're like the Master's
gone we compelled this guy to make the
calf now we're gonna do our thing right
because now we're going to enjoy all
those things that that we were never
able to enjoy in our enslaved condition
um and so so we've got that
the Tabernacle I think it's really
interesting because what's happening
there is to try to present in an
architectural space
um the possibility for the encounter
with the infinite right so you've got
this finite construction and this is
obviously how
um icons work and so forth how do you
solve this problem you know but it's a
very interesting contrast because
um there is a proper place for
um gold and silver and adornments and
these technical products
um yeah so yeah no yeah I think your
Insight is is very is very strong you
know there is a so you could say so
think about like even in the garments of
skin situation and it's very interesting
because you know God gives Adam and Eve
these garments of skin which by the way
many at least in the Orthodox tradition
and I'm pretty sure in some rabbitical
traditions as well it's kind of like
it's basically your biological body it's
like it's it's your biological body of
death right not that Adam and Eve didn't
have bodies before the fall but that
their bodies were more subtle you could
say and that these bodies of death that
we're in you know that you eat and that
you excrete and all of this and and all
the the desires that come with it
they're they're related to the garments
of skin and so there's a relationship
and what it does it's an increase in
power right body is an increase in power
just like a guy who is buff and has big
muscles has more power more you have
body more you have power and so it's
it's an extension of that logic which is
that if I add more body
I add more power if I have a if I'm
strong and or if I if I have a Mecca
suit on top like we said then that Mecca
suit makes me more powerful but there's
a connection between that and the
animality itself right the fall into
animality you could say which is also an
abandonment to our desires and to to the
to the more you know appetite aspect of
who we are and so like if you think
about it it all kind of comes together
so we tend to oppose for example
the world of technology in the world of
animality because one is artificial one
is natural but if you understand it as
this idea of increase in body then the
idea of a metallic calf right a metallic
animal which is you know God told Adam
to name the animals
and all of a sudden they take the animal
and they put it up as a God they're
basically doing the opposite of what God
told Adam to be which is to to be on top
of the animals and name them and now
they become subject to it subject to the
body subject to the this these kind of
licentious desires and so all of this
stuff kind of goes together you know in
the Book of Revelation there's this
image of the and the Beast right
so there's a sitting on the on a
beast and the Beast is civilization you
know there are different ways to
understand that in the text because the
beasts are related to the Book of Daniel
and the perception of the different
civilizations uh that like you know the
different animals and so it's like these
two things go together
right the technification and increase in
power leads to licentiousness and leads
to us being having more e and you can
think about it just like
just very practically which is that if
you let's say you you have a little
let's say you have a little fault in
yourself right you I don't know you have
you you look at women or whatever you
have a little thing then now I'm gonna
get and and that's kind of there you're
you're trying to manage it but you're
struggling and I'm and I'll give you a
million dollars
right it's like all of a sudden your
increase in power becomes a door for
whatever that little thing in you was to
increase and so technology does that
does that on steroids especially
something like information technology
right which is intelligent technology so
the relationship between internet and
porn or Internet and and all these
things this isn't something which is
completely unavoidable like you couldn't
have it any way else or at least not
easily uh you know it's not accidental
that these things developed the way they
did just as it's not accidental that
they develop towards porn and the
military it's like increase in power
increase in desire increase in desire to
dominate to consume all these things are
related to what technology is and
Technology does
yeah yeah that's very interesting you
know one way to think about these things
or at least one way that I think about
them is in terms of the categories of
work and Leisure so
um human beings relate to reality
work is a kind of sorting of Chaos
what's the point of work
um well let's go back to the Greeks so
Aristotle says he's critiquing the
Spartans war is for the sake of peace
and in peace we have business and we
have Leisure and business is for the
sake of leisure right now
we need a sort of thick conception of
leisure so I think here are
productive conceptions of leisure
um for Aristotle what's Leisure for he
critiques the Greek so they sit around
they drink and they tell Miss and stuff
although I think he's underestimating
the importance of this Jonathan and the
symbolic richness and so forth but
um what's Leisure for from the biblical
perspective let's take the Jews Sabbath
Sabbath and what is that it's that's an
opening again to the highest things this
is connected right with someone like
Joseph peeper who incidentally you know
I mean he has got this wonderful Book on
a Leisure of the basis of culture and he
sees Leisure as a kind of plugging into
the life-giving forces
um of the Divine of nature
and so forth
what's happened so why do I mention
leisure now I'm thinking of AI again
uh two things
um work and Leisure have become confused
so you were talking about the capture
stuff right
um
you're actually working for AI when
you're doing capture but why are you
entering captcha because you want to get
to the
the good stuff because you want
entertainment
um or every time I you know log into
this or I'm like I'm gonna have fun I'm
gonna watch this Tick Tock or something
they're getting information about you so
you're actually working
but you're you're working for somebody
else you don't even know it but you're
enjoying leisure
what happens with leisure well this is a
very serious problem
I mentioned Joseph Bieber
he's writing he gives us talk on Leisure
the basis of culture and another one
called the philosophical act it's
1947-48 after World War II
Europe is being rebuilt
the emphasis in education is on you've
got to have useful knowledge right it's
all for work and people is worried about
a world of total work
where we don't have exposure to Leisure
another person who worried about Leisure
is John Maynard Keynes who wrote an
article in the early 30s called economic
possibilities for our grandchildren
and Keynes this is a very important
Keynes said this is the beginning of the
depression and he says basically
obviously paraphrasing look readers
you're not going to believe this but
here's the good news
um in a hundred years we won't need to
work okay because our productive
capacities will increase and so forth
and then we're going to confront the
greatest problem in human history what
do we do with our leisure
and the reason that's a great problem is
we don't educate people for leisure go
back to Aristotle he was critiquing the
Spartans they don't know how to be a
Leisure all they knew is how to win Wars
yeah
um so so what happens with our Leisure
well in Leisure you
you know I have a statement around here
somewhere but the uh
some the world development organization
says something like AI is going to be
awesome
it's going to liberate all these human
capacities we're going to be at leisure
because it's going to put all these
people up we won't have to work right
and you know we're going to develop
ourselves we've got paint we're going to
have you know learn languages and all
this stuff
well much more likely you know you're
gonna have sex that's right most likely
so so there's this kind of um
you know we
this is why I think I mean one reason
why this is just profoundly
destabilizing but just to go back to
your point okay so we we our our bodies
are bigger we have more control
um
it's a disordering because the the point
of Technology was to do the work part
and now the technology is like oh we're
going to give you the Leisure stuff but
you haven't ordered like you you've lost
the order in some way yeah so then oh
man that image is per like I think your
inside is perfect it helps me understand
even more
like the idea of the and the Beast
that these two radicals right it's like
this this kind of this work and this
Leisure that is that is licentious
licentious and and loss in terms of
purpose right it's just kind of wasteful
uh
and that there is something about the
days of the week and Sabbath that the
structure of creation itself which are
the proper relationship of all these
things to to all these things so it's
like in some ways you could say
the whole purpose of the week is to lead
to this moment of rest like rest in in
God and so it properly aligns things
where it's like the work is there
towards so you can imagine like a ritual
like a ritual in the in the Tabernacle
or or liturgy in church right so it's
like we we're we're doing all these
things
so that finally we come to the point
where you know we receive the blood the
the blood and and wine and we kind of
enter into this moment this tense ended
moment and so it's like that would
that's and then we sit together and we
eat and we have we Feast it's like
that's the Leisure like the Leisure is
right it's it's rightly ordered right so
then the Leisure instead of being the
lowest thing which it is in our society
it becomes the highest thing actually
becomes like a kind of it transcends
work in that way like in in the the
right way of thinking about that yeah
and I it's so important you said we sit
together and we Feast
um human beings are social and political
animals we re We crave even if we don't
know it
the meaning that comes through
through rich connections with other
human beings
um technology today is sort of driving
us apart I mean again and Leisure today
and technology and Leisure today is
actually fragmenting us yeah that's
right all these forces of atomization
um even simply you know so I have a
colleague and he said uh well let me
tell you my daughter she's like 17. she
had her uh iPhone and uh it was ringing
and it was her best friend and she said
to her dad what do I do like why does
she want to call me
and he says well you actually have to
answer the phone to figure that out
right I'm just telling the story because
you know now it's like text right so so
but you're right entertainment I mean
what is entertainment there used to be
these things called movie theaters where
kind of cool things would happen
sometimes you know with audiences and
the way people reacting and just the
buzz and all this stuff and workplaces
are emptying out people are going to be
put out of work by the way many people
will think this is some kind of um
amazing blessing uh so you were talking
about money I gave you the million bucks
um my son had a teacher when he was in
eighth grade who was doing a documentary
on what happens to lottery winners yeah
they all go sour they go nuts
um and this is actually another problem
that you know we can discuss so that's a
great image of what's coming like if
it's true that AI is going to make us
not work then look at what happens to
lottery winners oh exactly um and and it
and it also comes down to
sort of fundamental questions sort of
moral questions because
if you pull Americans UH 60 70 don't
like their jobs okay here's the thing
though you go to work you get a paycheck
you come home you put food on the table
you can buy your kid a bike you can you
know there's dignity your life has some
meaning now I just took that away from
you right and I took away from you so
the guy who wins the lottery first thing
he does he quits his job and he moves
great all that structure your friends
who used to have
the the kind of basic architecture of
your life is gone yeah now what are you
gonna do yeah
um so I mean these are really really
fundamental problems um
yeah and it's interesting I was um
I actually it's so funny because we're
talking about this I just came back from
Greece I went on this this trip with
Ralston college and we kind of visited
all the ancient sites and we we also
went to mount Athos together and uh you
know you look at the life of the monks
and the they probably have more leisure
than any of us you know it's a it's
bounded with a lot of work so they have
like a certain amount of hours of work
and then they also have all this this
you know they kind of have this this
leisurely uh life but their Leisure is
really directed in that direction like
it's directed towards you know uh
self-transcendence really like you know
worshiping God and moving moving towards
that which is uh which is the good the
true and the Beautiful You know and so
yeah so so the so there's an image you
know I I in in the Book of Revelation I
talked about the the and Beast
right there's another image in the Book
of Revelation which is the Heavenly city
right the Heavenly Jerusalem and
Heavenly Jerusalem is also a technical
image just like the Tabernacle or the
temple it's a city now it's it's but it
also has that order you could say where
it's like everything is directed towards
God and so it says the all the nations
bring their Glory into the the the city
right all the kings give up their crowns
basically to that which is high and so
it's like Civilization technology but
directed towards that which is good
serving in basically serving it and
therefore making what they have
meaningful right and so there's a sense
in which you know I wanna I Wanna Be
careful with people like I'm not
anti-technology myself and I'm sure
you're not as well that technology could
be amazing
like of course if if we were oriented
properly
it could be it could be an amazing thing
full of Glory but the difficulty we have
is that we approach technology like the
the ancient Israelites approach the
golden calf or you know like something
to or even how Adam and Eve approached
the app was like something to take it's
like it's mine I'm gonna I'm gonna make
myself more powerful I'm gonna make
myself more and in doing that already
like you said the problem is that the
very that very mechanism makes it
impossible for us to
approach the rest properly because like
it's like we're we're trained to make
more money now right it's like our whole
education systems have become more
powerful make more money develop
technology everything is focused on that
but nobody asks what it's for like
nobody really is asking the question
like what could this really be for yeah
look
of course I agree with you um
I mean
I I'm not anti-technology I uh whether I
wear anti-technology or not would be
completely irrelevant because it's here
to stay we have to live with it
um it does make many wonderful things
possible this conversation right here
wherever we're talking to each other in
real time and and others can listen to
us I think it's it's really wonderful
um
but here so maybe one way to to put this
is
um in terms of the thought of Henry
Adams so I within the last year or two I
read um Henry Adams um
um the education of Henry Adams and it
was quite
it's really an amazing book um so Henry
Adams is born in 1838 and
um he he's the son he's the grandson and
great grandson of two American
Presidents right uh and so he's like
high up there and they live in Boston
and he says uh
um and and he has this kind of moral and
religious education and and as a boy he
says Boston has solved the universe
right like look at these Unitarian
clergymen the wonderful Civic everything
is wonderful fast forward to 1900 right
you've got
um you've got like uh eventual electric
lights telegraphs telephones right steam
engines Railways uh finally airplanes
you know you've got Darwinism Marxism
freudianism you have a radioactive decay
of the atomic nuclei had been discovered
and so forth and science is saying oh
border is an accidental product like it
doesn't it's not natural and human
beings are like or vibrating balls of
motion and stuff like this and what
Henry Adams says is in this period
um
what he symbolizes as the virgin
had been eclipsed by what he symbolizes
as the Dynamo okay and he ran into they
had these big dynamos at like Chicago
World's Fair and stuff and he saw these
things amazing so
uh he has this theory of History which
is human beings and this is really
relates to the ancient anthropology we
sort of are what we pay attention to and
direct our energies to and for Millennia
it was Christianity right it was
biblical religion and it it produced you
know Crusades and Cathedrals and music
and all these wonderful things
now it's the Dynamo
so the Virgin appeals Works through the
heart and the Mind through love
and appeals to this higher element the
Dynamo is something completely different
it promises material salvation in this
life not salvation the afterlife and
it's Dynamic it keeps changing and
um I guess I would say the problem is
that we relate to this moving thing
right and then Adams has what's famously
known as the atoms curve which is he
calculates he's doing coal production
from 1800 on every decade the power
available to human beings
technologically doubles yeah now so the
rate of acceleration is the same but the
Curve
at some point becomes super steep yeah
like it's like yeah and so the problem
is we don't really know how to how to
deal with it because it's too fast yeah
and it kind of just explodes our life
yeah so I I I I don't know it seemed
like that can't go on forever I don't
know because also just for the for human
capacity to to deal with it because it
will at some point we'll also we also go
insane because the right the the also
because we don't it seems like that
curve there also seems to be a trade-off
that humans make which is that like you
said we are what we care about and so we
also can't care about this Dynamo
uh at the same level as we care about
and care about wisdom at the same time
like it's either the the hierarchy as
soon as it's inverted it's real so as
this technological stuff improves our
capacity for wisdom our capacity to
discern you know becomes less and less
because the technological process makes
it so right a chip that increases the
power of a computer doesn't care where
it's used right it doesn't it can be
used to to power any video games or it
can be used to power a missile uh or you
know a weapon doesn't matter well and
look you know you you mentioned the
computer chip so
um doubling every decade well since 1970
uh the the
capacities and uh you know memory
storage and stuff like this and speed of
processors has doubled every year or two
and now we add artificial intelligence
who's
curve or progression is literally
unmeasurable by human beings because we
don't actually understand how it works I
don't even know what's going on it's
like a black box right so Henry Adams
actually says
um look you know at some point the human
mind might just crack up like a meteor
bouncing into the Earth's atmosphere
right now when you add in I'm just going
to throw this out when you add in how
technology is used today
um social media
um and all these other things well you
know
a rapid increase in mental illness like
the crack up is already happening and
and because you also have you know you
know cyber bullying and all these other
phenomena and so forth and incidentally
AI is is also being used you know
Department of Defense and the National
Science Foundation are developing
increased tools and manipulation and
surveillance and propaganda and all
these things so yeah whatever's
happening in public you know there's 10
times more things happening right
outside of our perception let's say so
if we added like the ideological
component of it too which is you you
have your own thinking and you get shot
down so you put your head down
I think it actually encourages the
development of two kinds of human beings
and let's use the image of hitting the
the like the atmosphere
um the hard dense aerodynamic Soul
that's like gonna just you know like you
know and some of my examples like you
know homo sovieticus you know the
tremendous pressures of Communism and
these are the the commissars you know
yeah but much more common today is hey I
don't want to crack up on the atmosphere
I am going to be weightless I'm going to
be empty I'm going to throw over all my
convictions I'm just gonna you know
because wherever the wind is blowing
that's cool right and and so we see
these kind of psychological reactions
um with this incredibly steep curve of
Technology with all the pressures that
come with it yeah
it's it's definitely going to it it's
definitely going to be interesting you
know one of the images again sorry to
keep coming back to the Book of
Revelation yeah sure it's just because
it's one of the best images because one
of the the images that that comes about
there's two actually one is of course
the Beast the Beast that speaks right
the image of the Beast that speaks and
that's what seduces everybody it's very
fascinating but the other one is that at
some point the Beast kills the
right in the story so the idea is that
this Horror in these this is
riding this beast and it's like
everybody is putting all their seed into
the like everybody's just like
just just chaos and mixture and you know
whatever all the possibilities but at
some point
the Beast kills the and it's like
because like you said
at some point the the the the the the
the the
control aspect of the technology and the
the surveillance aspect all of this
stuff is going to ramp up to a point
where
the very mechanisms that brought about
like the like the licentiousness are
going to turn into hard steel right and
they're just gonna gonna control
everything because as things Fray and I
think break apart and that's people's
mental health breaks apart there's no
other solution except to create top-down
structures that will hold things
together because obviously
you know whoever holds the reins of
these Technologies has no has no there's
no Advantage for them for like Anarchy
to break out and things to kind of to
become chaotic and so
it seems like the the vision of AI is
becoming more and more just a use of of
tranical control
seems like it is an inevitable and this
is like you think if you Game Theory it
out you see that it it plays out there's
almost there's almost no way around it
which is because I I I've been talking
to a lot of AI Developers
I think as I'm thinking about this and
and there are these like cowboy AI
developers right some of them that are
saying like kind of Elon Musk attitude
where it's like well this is inevitable
what's going to happen so let's make us
as powerful as possible let's put the AI
in your pocket right let's make your
phone powerful enough that you can have
open AI like independently in your phone
and you are like as powerful as any
other other Ai and it's like I get it
but
that's not gonna work right because
so so so either the either the powers
that be that hold the reins of our
societies are going to use AI to control
us or either we're going to be Cowboy AI
people and it means that the terrorist
is going to be is going to have it in
his pocket too and it means that the
punk rocker gonna have in his pocket too
which means that the reaction will be
the same
right there's no other way there's no
like there's just no other way uh that
it could play out it has to transform
into into surveillance and control I
don't see an if you if you have another
way to see it playing out I don't see it
it doesn't seem possible no I don't I
mean I hate to say it but I I think
you're absolutely right
um
and there are so many forces that that
exacerbate this uh
you know
um
there's a there's this kind of feedback
loop because the the less we
uh or the more atomized we become the
less
we even remember what it's like to be in
a kind of local community the more we
look at others
through this lens of abstraction you
know it's like it's like it's like the
Plato's Cave image you know he's got
this image of people sitting around
prisoners in the cave looking at Shadows
the difference between my being able to
turn my neck which apparently you can't
do in the cave image and look at the
other prisoner
versus getting all my information about
the guy who's sitting next to me a
shadow on the wall
uh like we're not doing that
face-to-face stuff this is a wonderful
moment right somebody comes down and
unchains the Prisoner and he makes him
stand up and turn around and it's like
the first contact with a human being
you know what what's going on right we
have to somehow be able to do that but I
don't see how that's going to work so
top down Solutions
um
well actually even let me let me go back
I said top-down Solutions uh
the word solution
I almost want to excise it from the
political vocabulary because politics is
a living ongoing thing
it's a constant renegotiation it's a
constant putting new and fresh energy in
to the system like you're like you got
to paint your house you know you got to
take care of things yeah it's a living
organism really right it has a kind of
opponent processing aspect to it where
it's like you push it a little harder
this way this way like right yeah so who
talks about Solutions well it's a
technical notion right it's almost like
a mathematical thing
um
and I I you know I kind of repeat this
phrase it seems to me that all political
Solutions like real solutions are final
Solutions right that is to say I mean
it's it it it's death uh it in some way
um incidentally Jonathan I've been
thinking about the 34th Kanto and The
Inferno where uh which actually begins
with the line it's quoted in Latin you
know uh uh the uh Royal the banners of
the king uh of of Hell Advance right so
it kind of identifies Satan as the king
um and and we have this image of Satan
and remember that he's he's like stuck
in the ice it's all Frozen it's all you
know
um none of the none of the condemned can
speak to Dante they're frozen in these
things right and then you have Satan and
one of the translators has calculated
that he's sticking up a thousand feet
from the ice like like Tower of Babel or
something like this right
um and
uh and in his mouth are you know Judas
and Cassius and Brutus and
um as this same translator John Sinclair
mentions
these are the guys who guys who serve
Satan best you know they're the guys
who's there but the revolution needs its
own in a way right I mean this
rebellious Angel Falls down and crashes
into the Earth
um and
um
so uh
I don't know it's just it's it's a it's
a very rich image
um but it's Rich it's rich in relation
to what we're saying which is that
you know the the image of Aaron making
the golden calf yes you know there's a
there is a relationship between that and
the the basic Promethean image of
Revolution you know and you see that you
know the idea of taking that we think
that we're used to actually think of the
Promethean story as something positive
you know it's like for me Prometheus
goes up there you know those horrible
Gods he takes the fire takes the
technology takes civilization brings it
down to to the human uh to the humans uh
and then interestingly enough Prometheus
is punishment is that his liver is eaten
every day and and for the in my
understanding that for the Ancients the
liver was a an image of emotion or
desire the Desiring part of the human
right and so it's actually an image of
this horror and this Beast again it's
like if you he brings technology to the
service of man and then falls into a
cycle of Desire that of his like being
eaten his own desire being eaten and
returning and being eaten and returning
you know it's like you the hunger of uh
of insatiability you could say is it's a
weird image of that
um
and so that there is a relationship
between so it's like if
so once again it's like it's not that
the fire is is evil right even in the
story The Fire is at first given by Zeus
if I remember and then take it away
because because people don't aren't
offering proper sacrifice then the fire
is kind of taken away and then
Prometheus takes the the fire and so
think about that like that's what the
story of Cain is the cane the sort of
Cain is so similar It's like because of
an improper sacrifice Cain has to steal
that they make civilization you know he
he's alienated from God then he creates
the first city out of this like I'm
gonna do this for myself to protect
myself from others to protect myself uh
uh and then in the story of the Bible
what happens that God Saves that you
could say it's like God redeems that
through stories like he takes what Cain
develops and then transforms it into the
Tabernacle transforms it into to the
temple basically uh but this idea of
the the this this kind of and the
frozenness is perfect for that right
it's like because that's what technology
is it's a fixing right it's like let's
fix these walls around our city let's
make these limits let's make these
artificial limits around things uh and
so yes your intuition is absolutely
right that there's a relationship
between all of these things yeah and and
actually it's a small detail but um in
Dante he Compares
um Lucifer or Satan too um so he's got
these bat wings basically which are
blowing and the wings are you know
freezing you know freezing the ice and
we all this water so it's like frozen
chaos
um he Compares them to um the wings to
sales on a windmill okay and then when
he talks about Lucifer's teeth eating
these guys because he's constantly
eating these eating nothing on them
which is also by the way an image of
insatiability um yeah yeah he Compares
it to what he called well it's a Hackle
which is some kind of agricultural tool
okay so this is kind of mechanistic
thing
um Prometheus is it's actually very
interesting
um God Zeus finally gets back at the
human beings with by creating Pandora
okay and Pandora it's very interesting
so this is where we get a mixture of
erotic desire
with technology why because what happens
is Athena makes this beautiful garment
for her okay it's this lovely thing and
Hephaestus gives her a crown uh
intricately worked and of course the
fastest is the Craftsman God intricately
worked crown on which all the animals
are represented so it's like a whole
Cosmo song microcosm yeah right and so
here's man looking at Pandora who's
going to be a source of of ill and you
know trouble
um
and and what's the attitude the attitude
is
beautiful attractive woman sexually
attractive
and check out her crown you know
the ability to create at your own Cosmos
like there's a technological desire
there too right Hephaestus is
interesting by the way because
well
in The Iliad
um uh there's a scene where Achilles
mother goes to him to make armor for
Achilles
and he makes this incredible Shield but
Hephaestus has these um
robots the first robots in history the
little maidens life-like maidens running
around helping him and stuff
so he's already Associated fundamentally
with the kind of Technology we're
developing today but
he is the most Humane and decent of the
Gods he has been thrown out of Heaven
he's crippled he's all this kind of
stuff but you know when fatis who's
Achilles mother shows up he's like so
welcoming to her because she saved him
when he was thrown out of Heaven by her
mother or maybe her father because they
both attacked him you know I think it
was her mother his his mother and and
she and another nymph for something
saved him and nurtured him and he made
beautiful jewelry for them and so forth
so there's
a suggestion there of what it would look
like
to maintain one's I know he's a God
right but like maintain his Humanity
yeah and use technology yeah and I think
we can it's really important for people
to always understand like when we talk
about these stories that to be careful
of absolute moral judgment because all
of these stories all have a flip side to
them it's like you know you you always
have to be able to see both sides at the
same time you know which is exactly what
you said you know it's like the for
example medicine is a good example which
is that medicine is technology it really
is but there's a sense in which medicine
can be the type of technology which is
this the proper supplement right the the
type of supplementarity and ethnicity
which is there to to to help humans and
I think that like the idea that you
could represent Hephaestus as this
incestuous you know like freak that gets
thrown out and now because of that he
kind of he's the one who makes all the
all the toys he's kind of like the guy
in his basement you know the tech freak
in his basement because he can't fit in
into society like if that's a proper
image of of him for sure but there's
another image like the one you said
which is rather this this desire to help
right you know if you make a crutch for
someone you make it because you want to
help them you know and so there's a
there's a powerful image like we have to
always remember that Jesus was a tecton
you know Jesus was the son of a tecton
Jesus was the son of a technical person
and it's not a carpenter per se it
really is a a Craftsman you know
so so
um
when I was on vacation this summer I
read Paradise Lost which I hadn't read
before and it's quite amazing
um in the very first book of Paradise
Lost we were looking at Satan he's down
in hell
and Milton says something like
um
you know you guys you human beings you
take pride in things like Babel he
actually mentions Babel and you know
mining and all this construct he says
you should see what they built in hell
like that is you know there's no
comparison between the technological
capability of these fallen angels and
Spirits uh and human beings and it's
really quite remarkable right like they
excel at that yeah in this hell where
there's heat but no light you know it's
like this so that's a really interesting
warning
um
and uh yeah I mean look
um uh
the
what what has to happen today is that
the Dynamo has got to be informed like
we have to relate to the Virgin as well
as the Dynamo just to put it very
broadly and I'm not making a religious
statement here I'm just saying there's
got to be Transcendence in some way
um and and only then can we control it
and the reason I want to say that is you
mentioned medicine
well you know if you come in and you've
got um blood poisoning or something and
I can give you antibiotics or whatever
it is right and I Fix You great
um but now medicine is being used uh for
you know anything sex change
augmentation whatever
um it's because
we've got the Dynamo but we don't have
the version so to speak that is we don't
have we're not Guided by some kind of
um moral or spiritual measures that we
could attune ourselves to it yeah no I
think that's the right I think that's
the right I mean we have we saw during
the time during covet as well we saw
medicine become a political tool and you
know become a strange
a strange tool for control uh and so all
of these all of these supplements always
have this Duality to it and and you're
right that in some ways I mean the only
thing we can do and this is
you know because it's like we're just
painting this this monstrous portrait of
what of where we are in the future but I
think that the thing we can do which is
actually the way to Anchor the Dynamo is
to
you know is to go to church is to go to
participate with your family is to
re-engage at the human scale because
that will reverberate it's the only
thing that can really reverberate you
know it's like become a better person
become a loving father become you know
become a a friend like I know it sounds
catchy to say that but I don't see what
else is possible no look um
what you're saying is we have to engage
in the practices uh and you know like
set the thinking aside engage in the
practices
um and
the practice
is a source of understanding and that's
what we've gotten away from it but
here's the thing we have to be very
deliberate about yeah that's right we
have to say look you know
um in some ways that which was the most
natural for humans you know a thousand
years ago is now has to be the most
deliberate uh behavior that we can that
we can muster that's exactly right and
that means that
um with regard to all of our
institutions uh say schools
um
they should be in person they should be
in a classroom they should be with a
living breathing human being they should
be you know and as great as Zoom is uh
the difficulty is that
um you know you and I came of age before
yeah the smartphone uh and and all this
stuff
um so we actually have this anchor that
we can remember you know uh what happens
when when that that's not there right
then we actually and and I'm just
thinking of the future here because you
you know you you painted this
unfortunately rather plausible scenario
about kind of totalitarianism and so
forth
um so how do we prevent that right
um well we have to educate for the
future and we have to
um but so uh it's look I mean we each
have to do what we can do you know I
mean I know it's a sort of cliche but
it's not for us to finish the work
we all have to do what we can and
um and uh set an example for others and
devote ourselves to trying to
um
resist I mean I you know I don't know I
mean um
you can also run away and try to get off
the grid and so forth and I think that's
fine
some will do that and I think we all
have also our
our place you know you could say I think
it I think that there are people that
are going to break off and form
communities Off the Grid and they're
going to create little you know uh
rodrere inspired you know communities
that's for sure I think that is that is
almost inevitable and it probably should
happen but it's I think some people
still have to stay in The Fray and and
and continue to right you know and and
it's hard to know who who will do who
should do what it's a in some ways
that's between
you know that that's yours are on each
of our of our own story but uh but but
of course we also need to to have at
least I feel like I still need to have
one foot in the Matrix uh and and I
often ask myself the question when when
does it go too far like when should you
just step out I'm not sure I have that
answer yet at least for now I feel like
it's it's it's important to stay
connected to the machine to some extent
absolutely I would be uh very unhappy if
if you or people like you uh decided um
you know I'm not gonna do the symbolic
world I'm not gonna do anything I'm not
going to lecture I'm gonna go to Alaska
and you know
um make my own you know your or
something I mean and that God bless you
right but that that's that would be a
withdrawal of your best energies uh and
intelligence
um from um from the public space and
what we need to do is enter back into
the public space as living thoughtful
creative active individuals and and give
what we can
yeah
so Jacob thanks for thanks for this
wonderful conversations and thanks for
your time and also all the work that
you're doing to to yeah to to build some
to read sow the seed you know to kind of
gather together the the right Minds to
towards the future uh thanks for your
work as well on that front thank you
very much Jonathan it's been a pleasure